[Music]
in 2013
i decided to meet my enemies
i was a 27 year old award-winning
documentary filmmaker
and a proud feminist and i was
determined
to expose the dark underbelly of the
men's rights movement
at that point all i knew of the men's
rights movement was from what i read
online
that it's a misogynistic hate group
actively working against
women's equality well the vast majority
of my previous work was about women's
issues
i directed documentaries about
reproductive rights single motherhood
and the need for more girls to get into
stem education
so when i learned that no one had ever
documented the men's rights movement in
a film before
i saw it as an opportunity to continue
fighting for women's equality
by exposing those preventing it
so for one year i traveled north america
meeting the leaders and followers of the
men's rights movement
i spent anywhere from two hours up to
eight hours
interviewing each individual men's
rights activist also known as
mra and i filmed 44 people total
and there's an important role in
documentary filmmaking
as an interviewer you do not interrupt
so i'm asking questions and i'm getting
their full life story
and in the moment i didn't realize it
but now looking back i can see
that while i was conducting my
interviews i wasn't
actually listening
i was hearing them speak and i knew the
cameras were recording
but in those moments of sitting across
from my enemy
i wasn't listening what was i doing
i was anticipating
i was waiting to hear a sentence or even
just a couple of words in succession
that proved what i wanted to believe
that i had found
the misogynist the ground zero of the
war
on women a couple of times
i thought i had it there was one men's
rights activist that said to me
just walk outside and look around
everything you see
was built by a man
his statement felt anti-women i felt my
jaw clench
but i sat quietly as a documentarian
should
while removing all the space between my
upper and lower molars
after my year of filming i was reviewing
the 100 hours
of footage i had gathered replaying and
transcribing it
which believe me when i say no one will
ever listen to you more
than someone who transcribes your words
you should write that down
so
i was typing out every word meticulously
and through that process
i began to realize that my initial
knee-jerk reactions to certain
statements weren't really warranted
and my feeling offended didn't hold up
to intense scrutiny
was that statement about men having
built the skyscrapers in the bridges
anti-women i thought well well what
would be the gender reverse scenario
maybe a feminist saying just look around
everyone you see was birthed by a woman
wow that's a powerful statement
and it's true is it anti-male
i don't think so i think it's
acknowledging our unique and valued
contributions to our society
well luckily while i was making the red
pill movie
i kept a video diary which
ended up tracking my evolving views
and in looking back on the 37 diaries i
recorded that year
there was a common theme i would often
hear an innocent and valid point that a
men's rights activists would make
but in my head i would add on to their
statement a sexist or anti-woman spin
assuming that's what they wanted to say
but didn't
so here are two examples of how that
would go
a men's rights activist in mra would say
to me
there are over 2 000 domestic violence
shelters
for women in the united states but only
one
for men yet multiple reputable studies
show that men are just as likely
to be abused i would hear them
say we don't need 2000 shelters for
women they're all lying about being
abused it's all a scam
but in looking back on all the footage
i'd gathered of men's rights activists
talking about shelters
and all the blogs they've written and
the video live streams they posted on
youtube
they're not trying to defund women's
shelters
not at all all they're saying is that
men can be abused too
and they deserve care and compassion
second example a men's rights activist
would say to me
where is justice for the man who was
falsely accused
of raping a woman and because of this
accusation he loses his college
scholarship
and is branded with the inescapable
title of rapist i would hear them say
a woman being raped isn't a big deal
it's as if i didn't hear the word
falsely accused of rape
all i heard was he was accused of rape
of course rape is a big deal and all the
men's rights activists i met are greeted
as a horrible thing
to have happened to anyone
i eventually realized what they're
saying is they're trying to add to the
gender equality discussion
who is standing up for the good-hearted
honorable man
that loses his scholarship his job or
worse yet his children
because he's accused of something he
absolutely did not do
well i couldn't keep denying the points
they were making
there are real issues but in my effort
to avoid
agreeing with my enemy completely
i changed from putting words in their
mouth
to acknowledging the issue but insisting
they are women's issues so here are two
examples of how that would go
a men's rights activist would say to me
men are far more likely to lose their
child
in a custody battle and i would
counter well because women are unfairly
expected to be the caretaker
it's discrimination against women that
women get custody more often
i'm not proud of that
second example an mra would say to me
men are roughly 78 of all suicides
throughout the world and i would counter
with
but women attempt suicide more often
so ha ha
it's not a contest but i kept making it
into one
why couldn't i simply learn about men's
issues
and have compassion for male victims
without
jumping at the opportunity to insist
that women are the real victims
well after years of researching and fact
checking
what the men's rights activists were
telling me
there is no denying that there are many
human rights issues
that uniquely or disproportionately
affect
men paternity fraud
uniquely affects men the united states
selective service in the case of a draft
still uniquely affects men workplace
deaths disproportionately men
war deaths overwhelmingly men suicide
overwhelmingly men
sentencing disparity life expectancy
child custody child support false rape
allegations
criminal court bias misandry failure to
launch boys falling behind in education
homelessness veterans issues infant male
gen
genital mutilation lack of parental
choice once a child is conceived
lack of resources for male victims of
domestic violence
so many issues that are heartbreaking
if you are the victim or you love
someone who is the victim of any one of
these issues
these are men's issues and most people
can't name one
because they think well men have all the
rights they have all the power and
privilege
but these issues deserve to be
acknowledged they deserve
care attention and motivation
for solutions
before making the red pill movie i was a
feminist of about 10 years
and i thought i was well versed on
gender equality issues
but it wasn't until i met men's rights
activists
that i finally started to consider the
other side of the gender equality
equation
it doesn't mean i agreed with all that
they said
but i saw the immense value
in listening to them and trying to see
the world
through their eyes i thought
if i could get my audience to also
listen to them
it could serve as a rung on the ladder
bringing us all up to a higher
consciousness about gender equality
so in october 2016
the film was released in theaters and
articles and critic reviews started to
roll in
and that's when i experienced how
engaged the media is in group
think around gender politics
and i learned a difficult lesson
when you start to humanize
your enemy you
in turn may be dehumanized
by your community
and that's what happened to me
rather than debating the merit of the
issues addressed in the film
i became the target of a smear campaign
and people who had never seen the movie
protested outside the theater doors
chanting that it was harmful to women
it certainly is not
but i understand their mindset
if i never made this movie and i heard
that there was a documentary screening
about men's rights
activists that didn't show them as
monsters
i too would have protested the
screenings or at least signed the
petitions to ban the film
because i was told that they were my
enemy
i was told that men's rights activists
were against women's equality
but all the men's rights activists i met
support
women's rights and are simply asking the
question
why doesn't our society care about men's
rights
well the greatest challenge i faced
through this whole process
it wasn't the protest against my film
and
it wasn't how i was treated by the
mainstream media even though it got
pretty disgusting at times the greatest
challenge i faced was peeling back the
layers of my own bias
it turns out i did meet my enemy while
filming
it was my ego saying that i was right
and they were sub-human
it's no secret now that i no longer call
myself a feminist
but i must clarify i am not
anti-feminist and i am not a men's
rights activist
i still support women's rights and i now
care about men's rights as well
however i believe if we want to
honestly discuss gender equality
we need to invite all voices to the
table
yet this is not what is happening men's
groups are continually vilified
falsely referred to as hate groups and
their voices are systematically silenced
do i think either movement has all the
answers no
men's rights activists are not without
flaws
and neither are feminists but if one
group
is being silenced that's a problem for
all of us
if i could give advice to anyone in our
society at large
we have to stop expecting to be offended
and we have to start truly openly
and sincerely listening
that will lead to a greater
understanding of ourselves and others
having compassion for one another
working together
towards solutions because we all are in
this together
and once we do that we can finally heal
from the inside out but it has to start
with listening thank you for listening
[Music]
[Applause]
you